[Music]
hello I'm Greg Sandler the president of
reason i/o this month November 2017 we
have got a great free webinar and to
intensive online seminars on one of my
favorite philosophers Friedrich
Nietzsche one of my favorite works of
his although it wasn't actually one of
his favorite works his very early book
the birth of tragedy out of the spirit
of music and we're gonna be focusing on
the topic of the three noble responses
to life that's three not just to not
just do misiek and palo nyan but also
what he calls the Socratic and how all
of this responds to the problem of meal
ISM that Nietzsche said was going to be
the problem preoccupying not just the
20th century which we've already lived
through but the 21st century that we're
now in the middle of so if you're
interested in this we have one of them
coming up very shortly on Monday
November 13th from 11:00 to 11:45 that
Central Standard Time so you want to
check your time zone that is a free
webinar open to anybody who wants to
enroll using the link that you'll find
in the video description below and then
on Saturday the 18th at 10 o'clock and
in the morning and 4 o'clock in the
afternoon we have these intensive
two-hour long seminars seats for those
are limited there's only 12 seats
available for each section we do two of
them in part to make it possible for
people all over the world to participate
and to open up as many seats as possible
so if you're interested in these you can
click the link below it will take you to
the type form you can fill out all the
information and we'll get you into these
this is going to be a don't want to miss
definitely not the free webinar which
will go for 45 minutes 20 of that is QA
but if you're really interested in
Nietzsche and understanding these key
ideas you probably want to sign up for
one of these online seminars as well so
I hope that you find this this is
fascinating as I do and I hope to see
some of you there
[Music]